years of non-stop russia-induced
hysteria from the media
here comes a story that proves what
utter hypocrites they truly are
president biden clearing the way for a
russia pipeline after waving sanctions
on the company building the conduit from
russia to germany
but the collusion obsessed media oddly
silent on biden's gift to putin
especially after screaming russian
operative at the last guy
the president is a russian operative we
now have to figure out how to deal
with a president of the united states
who wittingly or
unwittingly has been compromised we're
about to find out if the new president
of our country
is going to do what russia wants yes so
far
no accusations of biden being a kremlin
agent from the dems or the media
and while americans are still being
pummeled with gas shortages
republicans are pointing out the
hypocrisy of letting putin's pipeline
flow
while blocking the keystone pipeline
no keystone pipeline for the american
people
but pipelines are plenty for vladimir
putin i i
you know i don't get it joe biden is
putting america last to be shutting down
america pipelines provide good
high-paying american jobs yet he's
letting vladimir putin build a pipeline
to western europe despite
his opportunity to stop it so you got
soaring gas
prices a shutdown keystone pipeline as
we lift sanctions on a russian pipeline
right after one of our pipelines was
shut down by
russian hackers which leads to the big
question
is it time to apologize to jimmy carter
for comparing him to joe biden
dana the walls are closing in tick tick
tick
it's all coming down it could be worse
than watergate
you got to make sure you tune in at 11
to find out what's going to happen yes
you got the goods with the exclamation
point i don't know what that's good
i don't even know if we're going to be
there the whole world could blow up so a
couple things
sure uh i remember i think it must have
been 15 years ago or so
sitting in a meeting back bencher i have
nothing to do with the meeting just to
observe
where president bush says to angela
merkel the leader of germany
why would you even consider a pipeline
that would hold you hostage
to the russian president what is going
through your mind this doesn't make any
sense
and we were talking about liquefied
natural gas back then america has a
great system
and it has done a really good job of
innovation and technology for liquefied
natural gas
it is here it is plentiful it's
available we could have actually
provided that
it is sort of strange to say the least
that the former chairman of the foreign
relations committee
is pushing our nato allies further into
the arms of putin
that part of me doesn't make sense i'm
baffled by the decision still on that
first day inauguration day to cancel the
keystone pipeline
they had to have that in the works for a
long time leading up through the
transition
into that decision that day one it's the
jobs here but here's what i'll end on
greg
what was one of the main reasons for
canceling the keystone pipeline
the cause of global climate change right
well i'm pretty sure that russia is
still a part of the globe
yes so the idea that we would not do it
here
but we would pave the way to make it
easier to do it there
is suspicious and i agree with you that
the media on this one
that's not good he lectured us feebly i
might add on the climate crisis
saying that we're we could be
responsible for this and then he goes
ahead and punishes us
but rewards putin is just absolutely
mind-boggling it shows you he was doing
it politically
it was a political decision to appease
the uh the bernie side
who would then support him juan who put
these sanctions on the russian pipeline
on the russian pipeline originally do
you know
no no i think uh his name might
rhyme with trump
was he the one that put no you don't
think so all right just checking
how can we spin this so that it's
trump's fault
oh i i don't know about uh need to spin
it greg
i just think that when you look at this
situation the number one priority
in u.s foreign policy is rebuilding
alliances that were in fact
you know damaged by trump and that
begins with the
alliances our relationships with western
democracies
and at the front of that line would be
germany and angela merkel
and it's pretty clear that president
trump you know he was dismissive
of her but also didn't understand that
germany for whatever
reasons didn't develop their own energy
sources and
needs needs that pipeline
from russia for their energy needs
so that's what president biden is doing
he
president biden said on the campaign
trail that he did he opposed the
pipeline because he has a lot of
discomfort with russia's behavior
towards us towards the
western allies but he is putting
america's interest ahead of his
discomfort with russia and saying you
know what if we can get
germany and the rest of europe back in
line with
our agenda especially in terms of nato
uh then let's do that let's repair the
relationship america's allies same thing
by the way in asia you know with
australia japan
south korea let's repair those alliances
to take on china but
this is putting something ahead of his
own political agenda it's not hypocrisy
it's smart ah he's really is the global
healer it's interesting that germany
needs a pipeline i wonder why germany
needs a pipeline
i thought all of those uh windmills and
solar panels were delivering
so much energy jesse that the pipeline
would be irrelevant
this is not hypocrisy after he lectured
us on climate change
how is this not the you look up
hypocrisy in the dictionary
this is the story jesse
uh he's not a strategic thinker gut phil
russ has been on the move for years they
invaded georgia
crimea ukraine they're putting this
pipeline right into germany to control
germany and split off eastern europe
from the rest of
western europe trump actually sanctioned
the hell out of these guys
and halted the pipeline and they
restarted it the minute
joe biden was inaugurated merkel wants
the pipeline juan because the pipeline
offloads right into her district and
they also went green and got rid of
nuclear
and coal so they need the gas none of
our allies want this
not france not italy not great britain
not ukraine
not poland nato is against this one
germany's the only one that wants this
thing okay
that's a fact and you know why ukraine
doesn't want it because they basically
make their pipeline
obsolete this just carves ukraine out of
the picture
and they don't get the transit fees so
russia is just going to gobble them up
and whose doorstep are they on next
poland's
that just brings us right back into
action because they're a nato
ally that's the real truth of this story
and i think you're losing the focus of
what's going on
why is this in our national interest we
have 30 000 american troops in germany
protecting the germans from the russians
and the germans then save that money on
defense
and then send the money to russia it's
gaspron juan
it's state-owned that's the kremlin
they're paying
money to the kremlin which the kremlin
then uses for i don't know
hacking paying assad
selling weapons to iran invading ukraine
and then we have to go babysit the
europeans again
take our eyes off the pacific how is
that in
our strategic interest it's not yeah and
by the way it was uh trump that
uh put those sanctions in in case i know
want
didn't know that you know degan what is
it with seems like the bidens
seem to have issues with pipes
i'm not touching that okay uh just
because
me talking about pipe is probably not a
good idea
for my longevity okay
the fox news channel yes but the
the big picture is that joe biden in
four months has taken us from america
first to america last no
america on its knees we biden is
geneflecting to putin in russia to china
to even iran he is taking a hatchet
he's demolishing our energy economy
handing power and control and wealth to
nations
that hate us nine presidents promised
energy independence in the united states
energy dominance and we got it under
trump
and biden has completely wiped that away
it is
making it has diminished our financial
strength
and our geopolitical heft on the world
stage
just in four months kill the keystone xl
pipeline
banned new oil and gas leases on federal
land
within a month he rejoined the paris
climate accord
oh as you've pointed out greg china is
continuing to build
coal-fired plants enough energy enough
electricity to power
germany and we've yet to get an answer
about the wuhan plague
that killed about three and a half
million people around the globe
on top of that we have people in vienna
getting ready or trying to rejoin
the iran nuclear deal what in the hell
is the wrong is wrong with this white
house biden
is a feckless weakling what is just like
the press corps who won't ask any
questions about this
what is going on why is he afraid of all
of these
nations or is he just scared of being
shamed by greta thunder
on the national stage ah greta
she is a true global hero hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else